as the corona virus pandemic continues
to spread across Latin America the
country with the highest death toll is
Brazil there the number of dead stands
at more than 7,000 in South Paulo
authorities have begun blocking main
avenues in an effort to reduce contagion
only an estimated half of the city's
residents are obeying social isolation
guidelines some say they have little
choice it is going to help a lot because
the number of deaths are just getting
higher and we need to do our best so
this is all over soon I think this is
very important to be isolated just leave
home those who really need to leave I
left because I have to work but I avoid
leaving the most I can Brazil isn't the
only country bracing for the worst of
the Kovach 19 pandemic in Peru's capital
Lima health care workers have held
street demonstrations over a lack of
resources and protective equipment
medical personnel also protested over
the mismanagement of 20 bodies of
coronavirus patients left unattended
over the weekend in the hospital
courtyard video has come out of the
hospital with bodies two days ago it
began to rain on all the bodies in the
open air
phears over COBIT 19 contagion have
sparked unrest across many Latin
American countries in Honduras hundreds
took to the streets of the capital
Tegucigalpa on Sunday to prevent the
bodies of coronavirus victims from being
transported for burial protesters
blocked roads
fearing becoming infected by the bodies
of the deceased we don't want them to
send people to be buried in this
cemetery because those people are
infected and there are a lot of families
here one of the strictest approaches to
containment has been from El Salvador
though some policies like the forced
long-term detention of people accused of
violating stay at home orders have
raised an alarm over human rights abuse
that a most part in a UN vs1 for now we
have been confined for 41 days in this
containment center we only ask the
government authorities to give us the
results of the Cova 19 tests carried out
in order to discharge us according to
the Pan American Health Organization
Latin America is experiencing what
Europe did six weeks ago meaning the
region is only now entering the peak of
the corona virus pandemic Manuel drop
Alok al Jazeera